[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas hoy comenzamos en
afganistán tras pasar 12 días reportando
sep la toma del poder por parte de los
talibanes así como las evacuaciones
militares nuestro corresponsal sigue el
pañero tuvo que regresar a francia pero
antes de eso tuvo que pasar en auto a
través de pakistán y el siguiente
reportaje documenta esa travesía
dejamos kabul
vamos a hacer un vídeo durante la ruta
hacia la frontera pakistaní
hay muchos puntos de control talibanes
pero los puntos de control se pasan
bastante fácil
para ello aerosoles
los talibanes son como la policía
nos estamos acercando a jalalabad
en jalalabad hay una presencia
importante del estado islámico en
afganistán t el estado islámico de
corazón es el estado islámico de asia
central y rival de los talibanes
así que esa la lavada es una frontera
difícil de cruzar
y mi conductor lo sabe
este era un punto muy peligroso muy
peligroso
una vez se fue muy cerca a nosotros que
el estado islámico disparó a alguien
dentro del auto aquí
hay talibanes en cada punto de control y
en cada punto de control alrededor de
jalalabad estamos cerca a la frontera
paquistaní
ellos toman fotos a las personas jóvenes
para identificarlas y revisan
aleatoriamente automóviles
estamos en la frontera cruzando hacia
pakistán en torkham está controlada por
los talibanes
acabamos de cruzar la frontera
fue tan fácil como yo esperaba
hemos estado atrapados en tierra de
nadie por tres horas entre el capitán y
pakistán
este señor lleva seis horas esperando
como esperábamos nada es así
pakistán ha cambiado la ley y es un poco
duro
estamos esperando a pesar de todas las
autorizaciones no podemos pasar
una jornada un poco un poco larga pero
ahora nos encaminamos hacia las zonas
tribales de la frontera
afgano-paquistaní
son conocidas como el ciber paz con otro
contacto que me está llevando a
islamabad
después de esperar seis horas podemos
sentir por lo que están pasando
todos los refugiados para pasar una
frontera que ellos quieren cruzar
es algo para meditar
cientos de haitianos parten desde brasil
con la mirada puesta en el objetivo
final que es llegar hasta los eeuu y
para eso utilizan a bolivia como un país
de tránsito hacia perú sin embargo este
es un camino lleno de obstáculos y
muchos de ellos terminan siendo
detenidos y son obligados a regresar a
la frontera brasileña el siguiente es un
reportaje de mary waka
esta es la frontera de bolivia y perú
según fuentes oficiales acá llegan cada
día alrededor de 400 migrantes haitianos
tras cruzar el territorio boliviano
desde brasil una travesía llena de
dificultades que incluye expresiones de
parte de algunos policías corruptos
según la denuncia de ronald peters
elige
bolivia está maltratando a los haitianos
eso es en todos los lugares por los que
pasamos ellos nos piden dinero
si uno no paga 20 dólares 50 no nos
dejan pasar en un disco pasado ronald es
uno de los migrantes afortunados porque
consiguió pasar al lado peruano al
contrario este año más de 5 mil
haitianos fueron detenidos en bolivia y
deportados en su mayoría hacia brasil 5
mil 418 personas hubieran pasado por el
territorio nacional de manera irregular
estas personas han sido intervenida
tras las críticas al maltrato el
gobierno ha firmado un decreto que
permite a los haitianos quedarse en
bolivia por dos años pero la mayoría
solo quiere seguir su camino hacia perú
una solución consistiría en darles
visados humanitarios para evitar que
sean expulsados hacia las fronteras por
eso es importante considerar esta
temática y ya en fondo dentro del estado
a través de la amnistía a través de la
visa de tránsito a través de la visa
humanitaria pero principalmente en la
región para que los estados comprendan
que cierre de fronteras se está
generando delincuencia en este momento
unas soluciones que sin duda habrían
ayudado a ronald ya sus compatriotas a
cruzar por bolivia sin problemas sin
embargo los operativos policiales
prosiguen contra migrantes haitianos en
su travesía hacia perú otro hito en su
ruta hacia eeuu
tras el fallo de la corte suprema de
mexico que despenaliza el uso de la
marihuana una localidad de morelos al
sur del país emprendió el camino para
hacer realidad su sueño de convertirse
en el primer pueblo cannábico del
pero buscando beneficios para los
pequeños productores y nuestro
corresponsal en ese país mario carbonell
nos lleva a conocer la historia
pronto estos cultivos de caña podrían
ser reemplazados por hectáreas de
marihuana los campesinos de tetecala
morelos al sur de méxico están decididos
a aprovechar un fallo de la suprema
corte que despenalizó el uso lúdico de
la cannabis para sembrarla y detonar el
desarrollo de su pueblo
mi modo de
esto de la marihuana como dije como es
una pequeña ayuda al bolsillo pues no
pienso sembrar toda la parcela si parece
que para empezar con una tarea que se
sembrará con esto sería más caro porque
prácticamente vamos a hacer el punta de
lanza nosotros aquí en morelos
como cándido josé velázquez ya está
preparado pero él va más allá queremos
sembrar la cannabis para sacar productos
para la salud
también para que nuestro pueblo tenga la
oportunidad de que la gente que venga a
conocer nuestros programas sea parte del
turismo que necesitamos en este
municipio
el activista alejandro velo llevó a los
campesinos a la sede local de la
comisión federal contra riesgos
sanitarios a solicitar licencias de
siembra ahora esperan respuesta y
advierte que si es negativa irán a la
suprema corte su visión no es sólo
sembrar sino convertir al pueblo en un
polo turístico y sea pues bueno primero
habíamos dicho el primer pueblo
cannábico de mexico después nos dimos
cuenta que sería de toda latinoamérica y
lo que buscamos es ser el segundo lugar
más visitado del mundo en cuestión de
marihuana únicamente después de
ámsterdam habitantes y ejidatarios
aseguran que ya es hora de que lleguen
las oportunidades que los políticos no
les han brindado por lo que si su
proyecto cannábico prospera harán que
los beneficios alcancen para toda la
comunidad
no hay edad para ir a la escuela y la
prueba está congo una keniana de 94 años
de edad ella inspiró un documental que
lleva el mismo nombre y que fue lanzado
el 1º de septiembre hace 4 años esta
partera decidió luchar contra la
deserción escolar por parte de jóvenes
madres kenianas inscribiéndose ella
misma en el colegio y ahora su objetivo
es obtener un diploma al finalizar la
escuela primaria el siguiente es un
reportaje de mondi gesmat y eloise melo
llama perfila si tiene rica cuba 14
esto siempre es desde la colegiala más
vieja del mundo con más de 90 años
priscila si bien conocida como gogo
decide ir a la escuela por primera vez
su objetivo ser un ejemplo para todas
las mujeres en kenia que a menudo tienen
hijos muy pequeños y se ven obligadas a
abandonar la escuela para crear
una película narra el extraordinario
viaje de esta maquinaria aunque nunca
había salido de su pueblo fue a parís
para la promoción con su visita y
estoy muy contenta con este viaje
especialmente con mi bisnieta para que
pueda ver y aprender la importancia de
ir y quedarse en casa
reyal y
yo creo que ella inspira a muchos
estudiantes en kenia y alrededor del
mundo a no abandonar la escuela
el director pascal pisón vivió en kenia
durante 15 años se enteró de la historia
de gogo en un artículo de la prensa
local que llamó más evidentemente a mí
me llamó la atención e inmediatamente
fui a kenia a conocer a gogó y cuando vi
el personaje su carisma su personalidad
su historia me dije que había
ciertamente un gran potencial para hacer
una historia de su último año en
primaria pienso que la historia de gogo
no se aterriza a todos en los países
occidentales donde a nuestros niños les
cuesta a veces ir al colegio y lo toman
más como un castigo
completo del diploma que les dio le
consejo si llamo del piso tú eso tengo q
o succión de colapsos yo creo que la
historia de gogo nos sitúa viene a los
países occidentales donde nuestros niños
todavía tienen problemas para ir a la
escuela lo toman como una restricción
la inscripción de gogo en la escuela su
establecimiento ha ganado más de 300
estudiantes con el estreno de la
película se espera cambiar de mentalidad
a largo plazo
gracias por haber seguido esta emisión
de corresponsales nos damos cita la
próxima semana siga con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom